Nguyen Bà Thương Bà, người phân hôm bộ mọi sợ Iran S. Mà ở Bà Cầy Tuy Bố,
chấm rất cảnh đọc cuối sử của Mỹ và Israel là điều kiện tin quyết để tiến tới hỏa hắn.
Hôm biểu tại Tehran ở Khẳng Đệnh,
Hẳng Động Cái Hẳng cuối sử này không phải là sự lợi trọng của chúng tôi.
Sư lợi trọng của chúng tôi luôn là hỏi sao?
Ông cũng cư gọi cộng đồng cuối thấy Hẳng Động trước khi quá mọi.
Nhắm nhanh chẳng xin đột lắm dộn sợng tại Thú Bự Tây á.
Tây ra nguc đề nghị hội đồng bó á lý nguc của biển pháp cám thiệt phu hợp.
Đông thường nhấn mạnh cho đọc đáp trả của Yran Không nèm và cơ cú xa lắng dành.
Mà nhăm và các cân thương quân sự của Mỹ đã tại không quạnh.
Theo hội chẳng lưỡi đồng đỏ Yran,
ý nhất bày chẳng tảm với bày người đã thiệt mạng,
và hôm một trong năm mười thành phố biển hưởng,
kể thực ký xung đột đủ phát,
căn thẳng đẳng đánh thích sĩnh tại Thú Bự Tuy trọng ngày 18,
nhưng tiếng lộn dụng được dựng nhận tại Thé Hé Răn.
Phía Mỹ và Yran Chuy đừng sao được lận mới về để xuất của Yran.
Chúc bởi cảnh chính sử dẫn Mỹ và yếu giữa đào với Yran đăng đào theo thang
thành một xuống bầu cú vực giọc lớn hơn.
Nhưng cua ra đang phải gấp dút chín,
thay các phương ám sơ tán công dân khỏi cú vực.